what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here to watch
today from charlie over at emergency
awesome doctor strange two
one division deleted scene and alternate
ending explained marvel phase four
clearly there's something i missed
clearly there's something on social
media that i have not caught
so i'm like all right let's watch this
and see what it's all about
damn like i just saw the title i could
i'm gonna watch this
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new doctor strange 2 video they
just revealed a whole bunch of deleted
scenes
from one division that we're going to
feature benedict cumberbatch's doctor
strange
teasing the movie so we'll break it all
down there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs confirming a bunch of big theories
a bunch of scenes
it's basically deleted at the last
minute he was originally a much bigger
part of the plot of all the episodes
than we ever believed
and some of the weirder more confusing
aspects of the show make a lot more
sense
when you hear what he was doing in each
of the episodes
if you're brand new to the channel
really videos for all the marvel phase
four disney plus series
be sure to subscribe to get all those
very curious to see if i believe this
is the next big one so careful for
spoilers for everything that happened on
the wand division episodes if you
haven't seen those yet
but i'll just start at the beginning
here and just number these as we go
along just to stay
organized but you probably saw this week
it was revealed that benedict
cumberbatch's doctor strange storyline
during one division started
with all the commercials those weird
fake commercials that you saw in most of
the episodes
so what was supposed to happen is that
prior to the events of episode 1
right after wanda broke down and created
the hex without really
realizing what she was doing just
letting herself be overwhelmed with her
grief and loneliness
after kind of being pushed there over
the edge by tyler hayward and sword
the really dark twist on that is that we
actually found out that he was doing
that on purpose
trying to get her to use her magic to
bring vision back to life so to speak
reactivate him
a working theory that she could somehow
reactivate vision's dead body
they've been trying to reactivate
vision's body through that whole
five-year time gap between avengers
infinity war and avengers end game
but he successfully pushes her into that
full mental breakdown
she creates the hex and the event is so
extreme in magnitude that it sets off
pretty much every single
magical alarm that doctor strange has
around the earth
helping him monitor magical cosmic
threats threats from other dimensions
because as he told iron man when they
had their big bro off moment his number
one job is protecting the main
mcu reality wait a minute okay
you something's blowing your mind that
i'm not understanding these
enlightenment so is it commerci
is the implication that the commercials
are like
a way of like sending a signal to dr
strange is that what i'm because you
mentioned the commercials
they start hopping on a hayward and
saying that hey we're just playing the
plot of the show for mayweather but then
saying that hayward intentionally wanted
wanda to resurrect vision
yeah right as we suspected and they
don't make that clear 100
that's it's more of like a theory left
kind of open in the show
he didn't make that clear it just
sounded like a implication
maybe there's more to come though maybe
maybe i don't know the countdown from
543 i'm like did i miss something
yeah he also kind of referenced that
when he was talking about loki with thor
earlier your brother
is on the list so of course doctor
strange sorcerer supreme would
sense when wanda created the hex she was
also doing it in new jersey just one
state over which isn't that far away
from the sanctum in new york city
so right after this moment the hex goes
up and wanda drives into west view
during the
opening scene of episode one with the
fake version of vision she created hex
vision in the 1950s with everything on
black and white and while that's
happening doctor strange is not able to
portal into the hex just to snap his
fingers and dispel the magic make
everything go away
because of the way wanda's chaos magic
works and scarlet witch has just gone
full blown comic books
too you are the scarlet witch
they explained during episode one of
those flashbacks that she was actually
born with chaos magic
in the way they clarified chaos magic is
that it's magic without a cost and it
also gives her the ability to weave
spells with magic
without incantations so she doesn't need
to learn a spell out of a book the same
way doctor strange has to learn like he
has to read a book to learn how to do
something before he can do it
that's why a little girl scarlet witch
here is able to stop iron man's star
tech bomb from exploding by throwing up
a probability spell before she ever
thought about studying magic
okay i did a video earlier this year
about why that happened so in the comics
scarlet witch when she was born was
actually imbued with chaos magic by
cathode
the god of chaos so that's why she's
born with this crazy op level of power
when she came into contact with a mind
stone it just amplified her power off
the charts so she always had access to
chaos magic it's just that after the
infinity stone encounter
it was like the tournament inside her
turn into this raging river
and that's where you get to that
prophecy about her in the dark hold
saying that she's supposed to be more
powerful than the sorcerer's supreme
doctor strange the darkhold was also
written by cathode the god of chaos
so that's why dr strange wasn't
immediately able to portal
into the hex and stop everything on a
dime the hex would not let him in the
magic was too powerful
i mean this is all making a lot of sense
because the first parts of this video is
like
well yeah i mean you reminded me of dr
strange so much and i'm like it does
make you go why didn't
you think he'd show up or something like
this right off all the magical alarms
the sanctum sanctorum and it's
interesting to think that they actually
had like all this plot stuff mapped out
for
why he couldn't go in there just yet so
they did think that through it so we
were going to cut away a bunch of times
to him being like why can't i
just keep going geez sorcerer's supreme
so dr strange's workaround for this
during the series was to try and
communicate with wanda
send her subliminal messages to try and
get her to realize what was happening
and snap
out of it doctor strange text messages
the person creating the fake commercials
that we were watching
okay episode one he was creating which
was meant to represent the bomb that
killed her parents
that's why you hear the arc reactor
sounds in the same ticking sound that
the bomb makes in the flashback scene
from episode 8.
it's also the reason why the same people
appear in all the commercials
the second one was for the strucker
watch baron von strucker the experiments
he did on them with a mine stone
strucker will make time for you
the third one was the hydra soak
commercial with the tesseract shaped
soap
and it was a huge metaphor for wanda
avoiding her problems calgon style
calgon take me away from all my problems
into a fake reality that i created for
myself the fourth one was the legos
paper towels which was a reference to
her oops quote-unquote mess
the numbers on your editing are
confusing the hell out of it
she killed inadvertently keep up the
good when she was trying to stop
crossbones explosion
in the yo magic one was meant to be dr
strange telling wanda about what agatha
harkness was doing to her
inside the hex so that also kind of
reveals that dr strange
knew about agatha harkness the whole
time snacking on her magic
all the time until she would eventually
just withered away like the other
witches from her former coven
later you do see her arms turn gray
after agatha starts to siphon off some
of her magic
in that last one the whole nexus
commercial was doctor strange being way
more overt about it trying to explain to
her how she was a nexus being in the
multiverse
basically like the same everywhere like
one wanda
that would have been cool in the comics
nexus beings with these big focal points
for energy which also
sort of goes hand in hand with the idea
that she's this mythical being
the scarlet witch but during the
commercial there's the dialogue saying
you should not take nexus unless your
doctor has cleared you to move on with
your life
and the woman picks up the nexus pills
from the doctor that was supposed to be
doctor strange more overtly referencing
himself
like doctor strange is the doctor and
he's telling him
dude like a regular and help her learn
about her chaos magic powers and start
this big prophecy in the dark hold about
her bringing about the end of the world
you have to remember the reason why he's
called doctor strange isn't because he's
sorcerer supreme he's called doctor
strange because he is a medical
doctor i would have never thought he's
called doctor strange because he's in
sorcerers pretty excited he was just mr
strange
until he got to the ancient one and then
you know after all of that he finally
got his doctorate in the mystical
okay so in the beginning of this i was
confused because of like how fast we
were going through it that i
i thought it was like oh is she calling
out to him in some subconscious way but
oh it's reversed dr strange is the one
and damn they they revealed that that is
nuts yeah and that's a whole facet
that's a like an onion layer of context
and story to drop on i can't feel bad
about theorizing that he would show up
down when
it was built originally into their
actual story
i still think it works in the context of
the of the show of justice yeah it's
just a subconscious commercial that
plays
from wanda's mind since that's the whole
thing is this is her creation so i love
how it still works in that way as
opposed to this plot device of doctor
strange is the one giving
these like mysterious commercials and
i'm like dude why don't you just throw
yourself in the commercials that
probably would have made it
a lot easier yeah this way he's trying
his best to break through and i guess
this is just
how he can best achieve it yeah you know
all this
type of abstract form of your
subconscious mind
then what would have happened after that
is that during the finale he would have
finally appeared on screen
taught her what it all meant how chaos
magic works in how to use those runes
that she uses to trap agatha harkness he
would have also helped her sort out what
was going on with billy
and tommy as well like they have that
big post credit scene
that was always going to be part of the
series teasing doctor strange too more
overtly
what happened was they had signed
benedict cumberbatch to the special
contract to do the one division episodes
all of his scenes
and then the virus happened so for a
number of different reasons they had to
rework a lot of the plot and they just
rewrote things and rewrote things again
the last minute when it came time to
make a decision about benedict
cumberbatch they opted to just leave him
on the cutting room floor so to speak
and completely rewrote the finale also
because they got rid of his scenes and
he was such a big part of the plot they
had to
rework and add some extra scenes in
reshoots later
like this scene where they're fighting
each other and she throws the runes up
around the heck
surprising agatha harkness during the
reshoots they had to add that dialogue
where she says
no one taught me how to do this because
they wanted it to feel like wanda
figured this out herself
instead of benedict cumberbatch's doctor
strange teaching her how to do it which
was originally what was going to happen
it's just so funny when you have like
that was a criticism i think a lot of
people have was like how did you learn
how to do this
yeah so quick we're just going to talk
about the fact that
yeah yeah like it worked in the moment
but there is that part where i think
one of us was even like actually
literally doing that so quick and then
to come to find out that oh it's because
of having to deal with the rewrites and
stuff dang it's crazy
something that's changed a lot to
compensate for cutting out a complete
plot line that really affects the growth
of this main character that is
that's nuts and it's funny to see that
both falcon and winter soldier and one
division had to deal with some version
of that you know be due to the pandemic
and everything
in some ways still works better that the
fact that doctor strange doesn't show up
because it's not about him at all
in some ways i'm happier he didn't
hearing about this like as cool as it is
now but it does also
clear up some loose threads yeah or some
logical gaps
it's like something and i've really
shown up it might have undercut wanda a
little bit but just knowing this is good
because it's helping me with some of the
gripes i had
yeah yeah and to know that it's not
their fault from a storytelling point
that it was
because of the pandemic they had to do
this yeah that's interesting you get a
pass marvel
the post-credits scene that they have
with her studying from the dark hole
trying to learn more about chaos magic
was always going to be part of the
series and it was always going to be a
direct teaser for doctor strange too
billy and tommy were always going to be
crying out to her from the multiverse so
to speak at least that's what they're
implying like they're crying out to her
from some other dimension and she's
going to go and try and find them during
doctor strange too
and when it came to teasing the villain
of doctor strange too because everyone
has theories about who that's going to
wind up being if it's going to be
cathode
the god of chaos because it kind of
seems what they're implying during the
series
seriously if it's going to wind up being
nightmare completely
i do love the theory that billy and
tommy crying out to her from the
multiverse or from some other dimension
is really a trick of the villain of
doctor strange too trying to bait her to
do something to use her magic
to bring about this prophecy that's
inside the dark hold
so essentially kevin feige says they got
rid of benedict cumberbatch's
scenes because they didn't want him to
undermine wanda's character arc during
the series
they were worried that if he showed up
in the finale that's all anybody would
be talking about and everyone would just
completely forget about
rwanda's character arc and kevin beige
said that he didn't want
one division as a series just to feel
like it was a glorified teaser for
doctor strange too
so it sounds like originally they had
planned for way more doctor strange too
crossover scenes and easter eggs
throughout
all the different episodes it confirms a
lot of theories because there were
various points during the series where
it felt like they were trying to
reference doctor strange too or benedict
cumberbatch's doctor strange in some way
yeah there's something refreshing about
hearing that kevin feige was like
we don't want to undermine wanda yeah we
don't want it to feel like just a setup
yeah yeah yeah like you've learned
you've learned from some past errors
sometimes some
movies and stuff don't feel that way
keep that spirit alive moving forward
that's cool
it's cool i like that after the one
division finale and after the falcon and
winter soldier finale a lot of the
people behind the series the different
producers
talked about trying to create the show
in the edit room the same way that they
create the marvel movies like they'll
shoot a whole bunch of stuff
they'll try a bunch of different things
then they'll try to sew it all together
in the edit bay so that it all makes
sense in some time
sounds terrifying quite as much on a tv
show
where you really have to plot everything
out pretty carefully in advance
so if you felt like there was some
continuity things on one division didn't
make sense
it's because they rewrote a lot of
things at the last minute
and tried some things that were
completely different from their original
plan that they had plotted out
but everyone let me know in the comments
what do you think about all these doctor
strange deleted scenes that we're going
to be setting up doctor strange to their
big crossover moments during the one
division episodes
do you think they made the right call in
just deleting all that stuff
and just leaving all their big crossover
stuff for the actual
i think they should have just made that
call a little earlier
to smooth a couple things out so we have
to wait too long to see
what's going on with that cannot wait to
see what sam raimi did with that movie
all right yeah can't wait to see the
trailer either that was a great video
damn a lot of [ __ ] information yeah
man dr strange was a whole
aspect of this show that was then later
removed and left for us to just
speculate about
the beginning there's something with
this emergency awesome edit
usually the countdown is like really
easy to follow but i'm like wait a
minute the numbers are happening so fast
tonight
these correspond did i feel like you
just had my mind trying to fill in some
gaps that
i was like oh if i just waited a little
bit it would have been fine yeah
yeah just psych you out though because
you're like i should be keeping track
of something what is the category of
things we are numbering and and how
should i keep track of them
yeah wow that was a lot of great
information damn i i overall yeah i
prefer the way they went i feel like we
gave our opinion on it already pretty
clear but yeah that was great that was
awesome
mephisto and also watching again was
like i forgot how grateful our vision is
now
yeah man and now that we've got like a
little bit of a distance from it
yeah weirdly even though it doesn't
necessarily feel like it in the tandem
of just how much marvel comes out
nowadays but
yeah all right guys well subscribe to
emergency awesome if you haven't done so
already
click that notification bell hit that
like button keep a lookout for when
we're covering loki and last but not
least
i'm gonna shout today chris wham-off
because dr strange was the one who was
helping out
behind the scenes in the shadows and he
wasn't asking for any of the spotlight
or attention for doing it and if there's
anyone at our patreon page who's
constantly helping out those
less fortunate than themselves it's
chris wham-off
constantly being a damn good public
servant
to the world to the world never stop
helping
people the way you do and you could
start today by increasing your pledge
by 150 more dollars help
us be able to just get an extra editor
for like
one more thing that would go a long way
these people on the streets who are
just having a really do you have to like
go there and help them like physically
be hands-on
what's more rewarding helping them we're
increasing your pledge
i think you know what the answer is
buddy
get those perks those rewards
by letting us have them and you just go
a little bit
less in your wallet become a producer of
the real rejects you won't get the
credit title like that
you'll be anonymous